il m'arrive de rencontrer parfois
d'autres créateurs de vidéos sur
internet youtube par exemple on discute
et je le redis un bruit je suis abonné à
ta chaine j'aime beaucoup et les gens me
disent avons agi crois pas c'est pas
possible comme si j'avais pas le droit
de mme abonnés aux chaînes des autres
franchement je regarde plein de vidéos
de plein de créateurs différents je suis
abonnée une centaine de chaînes et je me
suis dit que ce serait pas mal que je
vous parle d'une dizaine de chaînes on
va dire qui me tiennent à coeur extreme
warning vous n'allez pas retrouvé les
chaînes youtube de potes dans ce que je
vous racontais il y aura pas
malheureusement en squeeze me fais car
et au nord-mali vie qui vous voulez ça
c'est à qui elle joue parlait plutôt de
trucs un peu plus obscur un peu plus
personnelle aussi peut-être qu'à des
chaînes qui vont pas trop vous parlez
moi c'est ma came à 1000% c'est des
chaînes qui viennent du coeur c'est
parti on va commencer chaîne de malek
on commence avec malek c'est quelqu'un
qui travaille dans l'animation voilà qui
fait des dessins animés sur sa chaîne
youtube il a deux formats qui sont
énormes d'abord il a dérapé battle entre
des personnages de fiction par exemple
entre golden freezer et astérix a
demandé ajoutant que près de 50 des
impressions des genres tournante en fait
c'est dingue parce que déjà il ya le rap
faire la chanson tous à l'écrire c'est
génial et le dessin animé il est mortel
franchement c'est trop ouf ça dure pas
longtemps mais ça me rend dingue c'est
ce qui est un peu cartonné au début et
maintenant il a un deuxième format qui
est si telle série était un dessin animé
japonais il fait un générique de l'animé
japonais mais version game of thrones
est mortelle il a fait aussi six riquet
morty était un animé japonais c'est
génial franchement on a l'impression que
ça existe quoi les vidéos font à chaque
fois plusieurs millions de vu tellement
c'est ouf mais il n'a pas tant d'abonnés
que cela on peut réparer ça et en plus
malek a subi une petite injustice
d'internet c'est qu'en fait très
régulièrement ces vidéos se font
repomper par des pages facebook ou
twitter ce que vous voulez sans citer la
source plutôt que de mettre ça sur notre
page facebook ou twitter je crois quoi
partager le lien on sait bien aussi
voyager c'est de rétablir un petit peu
sa justice allait voir la chaîne de
malek c'est trop drôle
il sort peu de vidéo mais elles sont
voilà
ma romain alors qui est thomas romain
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille également
de l'animation décidément qui vit au
japon et qui a travaillé dans des
studios d'animation japonaise et thomas
il a un projet un peu fou qui postent
sur sa chaîne youtube
il demande à ses enfants qui ont fait
pas une dizaine d'années de dessiner des
monstres un peu style et un peu farfelu
et lui il est redessine en version trop
stylé et monde ça en vidéo donc il ya
ces enfants qui montre un petit peu
dessin qui explique ce que veut dire
quoi les couleurs qu'ils utilisent et
ensuite il ya thomas qui redessine ça à
l'aquarelle il rajoute forcément sa
patte il ajoute des détails et les
seuils en tout cas d'être le plus fidèle
possible au dessin de ses enfants et je
trouve ça trop cool
et si vous êtes des gros gros fan de son
travail et de ce projet là il a sorti
aussi un livre qui est un recueil de
dessins des enfants avec ses dessins à
lui moi ça me parle à 1000% parce que
voilà c'est un projet de dessin c'est en
vidéo avec des astuces avec ses enfants
pour sa trop cool winter gahtane
qu'est-ce que winter gahtane c'est un
musicien qui s'appelle martin qui a eu à
un projet assez dingue il ya de ça
quelques années il a fabriqué une
machine une machine avec des billes qui
fait de la musique vous êtes peut-être
déjà vu cette vidéo s'appelle la marbre
en chine
[Musique]
cette vidéo avait beaucoup pesé parce
que c'était absolument dingue de faire
une musique aussi stylée avec juste une
machine qui tourne et débit qui tombait
lui qui actionne des leviers c'est
absolument d'électro et il s'est mis
dans la tête de fabriquer une version
supérieure de sa marble machines et du
coup toutes les semaines ils postent des
vidéos pour expliquer comment il
fabrique cette pièce là comment ils
améliorent cette partie là ça peut être
des choix artistiques des choix de
matériaux il fait usines et ses pièces
en aluminium par dégâts chez paou qui on
voit par la poste et ils testent la
vitesse de chute d'une bille des
systèmes dément pour faire remonter
débit bref il est parti dans un délire
c'est ouf s'il passe pas loin de paris
un jour j'irai le voir en concert parce
que ça a l'air d'être du très très lourd
maintenant je vais vous parler de deux
chaînes en même temps pourquoi en même
temps c'est parce qu'en fait j'ai
participé récemment à chacun de leurs
projets yes vous aime et inherent net
j'espère que vous connaissez ces deux
chaînes donc d'un côté nous avons yes
vous aime un collectif de comédiens ils
font sur internet pas mal de parodies
des parodies d'émissions télé ils ont
parodié les petites vidéos brut bons
mois en faut savoir qu'à la base et
j'étais dans la rue pour défendre les
bagnoles bons ils ont fini par rouler
dessus par odile et vidéos youtube eux
les singes ou trop bien et a plein
d'idées et là ils ont tourné une web
série qui vont porter sur leur chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle abonne toi ou
c'est l'histoire du collectif yes vous m
qui va essayer de gagner de plus en plus
d'abonnés et ils m'ont fait participer à
leur petite série j'ai hâte que ça sorte
je pense que c'est pourtant pas très
très longtemps et d'un autre côté nous
avons internet c'est comme jeter
renaître mais sans le thé une chaîne
youtube créée par benoît blanc et
mathias gear big benoît blanc que vous
avez vu par exemple dans les vidéos de
mcfly carlito c'est lui qui a fait le
juge du dernier youtube warrior par
exemple et ces gars là c'est des fous
ils font de l'humour vraiment absurde
ils font une sorte de fausse interview
il faut un peu tout et n'importe quoi va
porter en short ou en grèce votre veste
on est sur scène ben oui forcément hélas
leur nouveau projet et j'étais très
content de participer à ça ça s'appelle
romans photos et ils font une aventure
dans un espace de coworking avec des
personnages un peu fou sauf que les gens
ne bougent pas comme dans un roman photo
elle flirte avec marcus au calme je vous
laisse découvrir romans photos mais
aussi toutes leurs autres vidéos ya ce
12ème et internet c'est vraiment deux
chaînes
français n'a pas encore explosé mais ça
mérite à mon sens c'est de l'absurde cdu
réfléchi quand même c'est de
l'intelligence et du travail c'est la
qualité c'est tout ce que j'aime bien
dans une vidéo youtube
simone hier on reste dans l'absurde avec
la chaîne youtube de simone voilà je
sais pas comment prononcer son nom de
famille donc on va juste l'appeler
simone qui est une suédoise qui fabrique
des robots absolument débile c'est des
robots qui ont une utilité mais sont
fabriqués de sorte à ce que ça parte en
vrille et un de ses grands succès c'est
par exemple son réveil mais débattre à
travailler elle a fait aussi une machine
pour s'essuyer les fesses avec une
perceuse coton mot dire que c'est
peut-être un peu trop efficace une
machine pour se brosser les dents une
machine pour boire des sous et
heureusement ça ne marche jamais c'est
ça finalement sa spécialité petite
précision les vidéos sont en anglais
mais pas besoin de parler anglais pour
voir une machine qui ne fonctionne pas
et puis c'est très souvent sous titré ce
qui est aussi fascinant sa vie n'a aucun
sens elle a vécu dans un bateau elle a
participé à des tournages de séries en
chine parce qu'elle parle un petit peu
chinois sa voiture ressemble un fromage
frais c'est un peu un personnage de
dessin animé on al'impression
malheureusement elle a sorti deux vidéos
récemment parce qu'en fait elle a eu une
tumeur au cerveau s est fait opérer
visiblement voilà les nouvelles sont pas
encore très bonne donc moi je lui
souhaite un très bon rétablissement
beaucoup de forces à simone
merci pour ce que tu fais courage thomas
gauthier
vous l'avez peut-être déjà vu dans mon
tour du monde parce qu'il m'a accueilli
à montréal voilà dans sa ville thomas
gautier vient du québec et il est sur
youtube depuis très très longtemps
depuis aussi longtemps que moi il me
semble j'ai l'impression d'être une
personne âgée quand je dis ça thomas
cotty il a fait toutes sortes de vidéos
dans des formats très différents et va
faire une petite fiction avec son
colloque qui va te faire des vidéos sur
n'importe quel thème
c'est ça que j'aime bien c'est qu'il a
beaucoup de liberté surtout c'est très
drôle récemment il a fait par exemple à
six mois qui s'appelle tabou il revient
sur des petites vidéos des faits de
société en quelque sorte si vous avez
regardé les nouvelles dans les cinq
dernières années vous savez probablement
déjà qu'il ya des monstruosités se passe
partout autour du globe et lui donne son
avis là dedans il met ça en perspective
avec des petits concept de philosophie
et à la fin ça se termine par une petite
chanson hyper stylé pour sauver la terre
pour de bon
yobo email solution faire cesser de
regarder avec des caennais il explique
aussi des moments de l'histoire un peu
pour les jeunes c'est un peu débile mais
c'est vraiment génial
elle fait aussi des webséries bref il ya
vraiment plein de cordes à son arc je
suis un des premiers abonnés de thomas
gautier vraiment je découvrais sad il ya
très longtemps et je suis toujours très
fidèle et merci de m'avoir accueilli
dans ta ville formidable qu'est montréal
franchement c'est toujours d'une grande
qualité tout en étant original et drôle
j'achète quoi là on a un concept
exceptionnel c'est ma came à fond qu'est
flipnote ça manquait un peu d'animation
on y retourne avec la chaîne youtube de
kéké qui s'appelle le kevin qui est
aussi quelqu'un qui travaille dans
l'animation kéké alors là c'est un
délire il crée des animations sur sa
nintendo ds c'est faire d'autres choses
mais ça c'est quand même sa spécialité
effet des courtes vidéos avec des
animaux qui y danse ou qui vivent des
petites aventures souvent c'est sur des
petites musiques style et c'est
improbable c'est trop mignon c'est trop
bien fait on sent toute son âme dans ces
petites vidéos ça que j'aime bien voilà
ça lui ressemble à 1000% dès que ça sort
je clique
j'adore mon témoin des animaux qui
dansent une baguette et un renard qui
font win-win je veux voir ça ça me rend
fou
on retourne au japon ça s'appelle
archipel parce que le japon est un
archipel c'est à dire un ensemble d'îles
cette chaîne youtube publie des
reportages sur des artistes japonais
mais aussi un petit peu d'autres choses
ils ont commencé avec un format qui est
mortelle qui s'appelle tokotoko qui suit
des artistes japonais qui explique un
petit peu leur art mais aussi les lieux
où ils vont régulièrement et moi je
trouve ça passionnant il va avoir des
musiciens des concepteurs de jeux vidéo
des dessinateurs des animateurs des
stylistes des sculpteurs de figurines
bref pleins d'artistes du japon maison
de plus en plus de formats par exemple
pour je sais pas moi parler de cuisine
ou alors un nouveau lieu bref c'est trop
stylé c'est hyper intéressant c'est trop
beau c'est sous titrée en français bref
ne manquait rien archipel c'est dans mon
top 10 j'ai rect cinéma vous aimez le
cinéma
moi j'aime beaucoup le cinéma
reconnaissez-vous cinéma avec un s au
début c'est une chaîne youtube qui parle
de science et de cinéma le créateur de
cette chaîne qui s'appelle jean baptiste
va prendre une thématique dans le cinéma
qui va essayer de d'expliquer par la
science par exemple il vient de sortir
là ya pas longtemps est ce que c'est
possible de créer de l'énergie avec des
cris des enfants par rapport au film
monstres et compagnie de pixar c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils vont encore aux
enfants pour remplir de l'énergie pour
la vie ou alors il a parlé de mécanique
des fluides comme ça c'est fait pas
avant d'aimer c'est absolument ouf pour
expliquer comment ils ont réussi à faire
de l'oipr réaliste dans pirates des
caraïbes c'est drôle c'est bien fait
franchement il ya plein de graphisme de
montage c'est ouf
le travail sur cette chaîne j'adore
l'eau c'est le genre de vidéo qui donne
envie de s'intéresser au cinéma ou à la
science et qui donne envie de revoir des
films et qui te fait rire
[ __ ] on va reparler du japon je suis
désolé pour ceux qui ne sont pas
sensibles au japon comme je le suis moi
ce top n'a aucun sens mais je suis
désolé je suis obligé de vous parler des
publicités japonaises les publicités
japonais c'est un délire de gens qui
consomment de la drogue qui font une
publicité il ya des gens qui sont
drogués avec cette publicité ça n'a pas
de sens je trouve ça tellement drôle et
intéressant et très très bizarre
du coup il ya des chaînes youtube qui
compile des publicités japonaises toutes
les semaines tous les mois vous avez des
publicités japonaises en vrac comme ça
pendant dix minutes et tu dis waouh
qu'est ce qui m'arrive
ça me fait voyager j'ai l'impression de
retourner au japon si vous voulez des
nouvelles sensations c'est pas mal dit
gladieux vous avez peut-être déjà vu ces
vidéos absolument débile à freddy il a
fait des petites vidéos qui sont devenus
assez connu par exemple le soldat est là
qui envoie de la viande
vous avez déjà vu ça qu'est ce que tu
fais là fait les voix aussi pendant un
match de football bat pour pas mal
travaillé sur deux papas ils aiment bien
interagir avec d'autres vidéos ou les
décortiquer mais parfois il va dans des
délires qui n'ont plus aucun sens
par exemple y décortique les sports aux
jeux olympiques d'hiver ski et les tons
qu'est-ce qui fait il en équilibre skis
sur les mains
je comprends pas il est surtout très
actif sur instagram et c'est stories je
savais pas qu'on pouvait dire autant de
conneries dans la journée je sais
qu'aujourd'hui il travaille avec ivy
qu'avec des gens comme ça parce qu'il a
beaucoup de talent mais rld est très
drôle donc du coup j'ai hâte de
découvrir un peu toutes ces prochaines
vidéos à notre ami freddy gladieux c'est
oui et voilà c'est la fin d'une petite
sélection de dix chaînes que j'aime
particulièrement j'espère que vous avez
fait un petit peu des découvertes et
peut-être des coups de coeur de votre
part aussi vous allez pouvoir vous
abonner à toutes ces chaînes là vous
avez pas mal de dos liens dans la
description dans tous les cas il ya un
peu tout et n'importe quoi dans cette
liste de chaînes youtube il ya quand
même un point commun c'est qu'en fait
ils ne publient pas très très
régulièrement sur youtube
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une grosse
tendance sur internet a publié de plus
en plus de contenu mais pour faire du
contenu original ou de qualité ça peut
prendre du temps jeu mais aussi en lien
un petit best-of de la chaîne les
internet qui met en avant les créatrices
sur youtube ce qui a très peu de femmes
s'est lui-même dans ce classement il n'y
a que simone malheureusement voilà c'est
un petit peu tout ce que j'avais à dire
aujourd'hui j'espère que vous avez fait
des petites découvertes et que ça vous
appelez moi je vous dis à très vite sur
internet pour une prochaine vidéo au
revoir